[Música]
es el momento exacto en que mi vida
cambió el día y el momento en que nació
mi hijo mayor
y este es el momento en que mi vida se
completó cuando nació mi hijo menor ya
era mamá de dos hermosos niños
resulta que con el tiempo me di cuenta
que yo no era una mamá común yo era una
mamá que pertenezco a un grupo selecto
dile que le dicen esa mamá
resulta que hace poco más de tres años a
mi hijo mayor lo diagnosticaron con tdh
de carácter impulsivo y hace unos meses
a nuestro hijo menor también pero de
carácter hiperactivo
th significa trastorno por déficit de
atención e hiperactividad es un
trastorno neurobiológico de carácter
crónico
es de transmisión genética en nuestra
fama la familia mi esposo lo tiene y
afecta entre el 5 y el 10 por ciento de
la población infantil a nivel mundial
casi el 10 por ciento
las personas que están afectadas por
este trastorno
son afectadas en tres vertientes
desatención hiperactividad e
impulsividad y en algunos casos hay unas
mezclas de esto
mi hijo menor el de carácter hiperactivo
tiene exceso de energía se la pasa todo
el día brincando saltando y corriendo
detrás de un valor es súper deportista
ama el fútbol para nadie raro ver a un
niño de 7 años corriendo de aquí para
allá detrás de un balón él no es
problema para sus profesores ni es un
problema para los demás adultos
mi otro hijo en cambio el de carácter
impulsivo es ese niño que termina
diciéndole ese niño ese niño que es
canson bullosa y grosero es un niño que
le cuesta trabajo parar pensar hablar y
actuar esa impulsividad no lo deja ese
ese niño que no se queda callado quien
no levanta la mano en clase
para pedir perdón
y dar su opinión constantemente está
interrumpiendo
todas estas actitudes que tienen
nuestros hijos las buenas pero sobre
todo las malas recaen sobre nosotros las
mamás sobre mí
y ahí es cuando las demás personas
empiezan a hablar a espaldas de nosotros
empiezan a decir eso es que son padres
ausentes eso es que no les prestan
atención debe ser que le compran todo lo
que piden y hacen lo que les da la gana
y a mí me dando como algo porque de
verdad que nada más lejos que es
les voy a contar como mi vida se fue
transformando yo era arquitecto y
trabajaba como arquitecto cuando
nacieron mis hijos decidí tomarme un año
para estar con ellos yo quería ser quien
los bañar a los alimentar a los
arrollara y hasta cambiar pañales
cuando esos tiempos terminaban yo
regresaba a trabajar y en la última vez
regresé pensando en que ya iba a seguir
pues con el trabajo normal pero al poco
tiempo empecé a ver que algo estaba
sucediendo
y algo como que no me gustaba entonces
tuve la gran fortuna de poder retirarme
del trabajo y dedicarme a estar con mis
hijos y apoyarlos y hacer ver a ver cómo
salían adelante
empecé a trabajar de la mano del colegio
buscando estrategias que le ayudaran a
mi hijo a salir adelante empecé a llevar
a mi hijo una y en algunos momentos
hasta dos veces a la semana a las
terapias empecé a leer todo lo que se me
ocurría y todo lo que me recomendaban
hay mil cosas ahí afuera que uno puede
investigar
e inclusive mi esposo y yo en algún
momento hicimos un curso de parent y
para ser mejores papás
en nuestra casa tenemos rutinas
establecidas tenemos normas y sus
consecuencias
nuestros hijos tienen responsabilidades
desde chiquitos les enseñamos cuando uno
se quita la ropa va a la canasta de la
ropa sucia cuando uno termina de comer
algo lleva los platos a la cocina y los
juguetes se guardan y se organizan
nosotros no somos padres ausentes y mis
hijos no son mal educados
cuando llegó el diagnóstico inicial me
sumergí por completo en aprender lo que
es el th el internet al rescate encontré
todo tipo de información unas páginas
fantásticas y otras no tanto
pero para esto mamá no era suficiente yo
necesitaba entender y conocer más sobre
cómo funciona el cerebro de mi hijo yo
necesitaba poder enseñarle a mi hijo
cómo es ese cerebro a que él se entienda
a sí mismo a que él aprenda a manejar
ese maravilloso cerebro que tiene
a que se relacione mejor con sus
compañeros
y poder ayudar al colegio a navegar este
diagnóstico porque la verdad es que
nuestro país y en la gran mayoría de los
países el td no es muy bien manejado en
los colegios los colegios no tienen las
herramientas o el conocimiento para
poder manejar lo que son estas
características específicas
así que empecé a estudiar por más de un
año como coach y específico del cdh
pero nada estas cosas son visibles hacia
afuera ni tienen por qué serlo yo soy
una mamá en función de mis hijos no en
función de los otros adultos de las
otras madres ni de las demás personas
que están ahí mirando de reojo
soy la mamá de un niño que en algún
momento yo llegué a pensar que no tenía
amigos y eso me partía el corazón
soy la mamá de un niño que a veces no
invitan a las fiestas porque lo
consideran canción
soy la mamá de ese niño que reactiva que
reacciona de manera impulsivo ante las
provocaciones de los demás soy la mamá
de ese niño al que por situaciones
constantes en algún momento me ha tocado
ir cada par de semanas al colegio a
hablar con los profesores o con los
coordinadores
soy la mamá de ese niño que recibe la
agenda ya no tanto antes más
con notas negativas a diario y si no era
la nota era la llamada telefónica
pero también soy la mamá ese niño
qué
que es creativo y que tiene unas
habilidades manuales increíbles
descubrí que mi hijo si tiene amigos
poquitos pero son super amigos
soy mamá de ese niño que es noble y no
vive enojado con esos otros niños que le
dicen ya no quiero jugar contigo o ya no
quiero ser tu amigo
soy mamá de ese niño que tiene una
memoria excepcional que con los exámenes
nos dimos cuenta que tiene un
coeficiente intelectual cabal catalogado
como muy superior y hace poco en las
pruebas del chiquito las de él dieron
por encima del promedio
soy la mamá de ese niño que piensa
completamente diferente a los demás
porque hace relaciones entre diferentes
temas que a nadie se le ocurre y genera
ideas nuevas
soy la mamá de un niño que es
completamente curioso y apasionado con
los temas que le gustan
pero también soy la mamá de ese niño que
todos los días me dice que me ama
todos los días me busca donde esté en el
apartamento para darme un beso y un
abrazo
soy la mamá que se siente juzgada todo
el día todos los días
soy la mamá que se siente sola soy la
mamá que vive exhausta preocupada
ansiosa soy la mamá que nunca estoy
relajada cuando salgo con mis hijos
y soy la que vive frustrada con las
demás personas sobre todo con los
adultos porque uno pensaría que ellos
tienen la capacidad de sentir empatía
hacia los niños y las madres hacia otras
madres
pero en todo este viaje
he reforzado varias ideas
y es que soy una mamá que ama con locura
a sus hijos soy una mamá que se ha
dedicado a aprender sobre ellos al punto
que me reinventé profesionalmente soy
esa mamá que entiende
que no hay nada malo con sus hijos y que
también he podido comprender que yo soy
una buena mamá
también
soy esa mamá que trabaja de la mano del
colegio de los terapeutas
y de los especialistas soy esa mamá que
está presente en la vida de mis hijos
y también soy esa mamá que ve un futuro
brillante para sus hijos
yo soy esa mamá
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]